- Ladies and Gentlemen,
the next time you see us,
we will be,
in Australia.
- Underwhelming.
- Australia. You ready, mates?
- Aw.
- That's what they say
in Australia, right?
Mate, and stuff.
Seafood. We're gonna go
eat some seafood now.
- Shellfish, actually.
- Today, in Warren, Australia, Part One,
we are gonna try three
different seafood dishes,
at three drastically
different price points,
to find out which ones are the
most worth it at its price.
Seafoods are my favorite foods.
- Are they really?
- (sigh) You know how you
can have more than one
favorite kid?
- I've never had kids, so,
I can't really speak to that.
- Yeah, me neither.
We are on our way to
the Sydney fish market.
It is going to be epic. The part about it,
- We haven't been there yet.
You just googled pictures.
- I mean, people will
just Google our show,
to find out about seafood. Same thing.
There's a pelican right outside
our car. It's beautiful.
- All righty. Let's go, pelic-in.
- Oh, I get it now.
(upbeat music)
- Ocean trout. That one. Fish head.
- No touching.
- The large coral trout.
Blue crabs? Orange crabs.
The cutest fish, the cuddle fish.
♫ Let me see those prawns.
- The tigers.
- ♫ Prawn, praw-praw-praw prawn.
- So you guys are sourcing,
these specific oysters,
from literally the place
that is on the sign, right?
- Creamy and sweet sounds nice.
- So, how many you wanna
get? You wanna get ...
- I think we should just get two of each.
- Who eats one oyster?
- Well we're gonna eat one
of many different kinds.
Am I crazy?
- Yes, you're crazy. We
should get one for Adam,
as well, though.
- All right.
I have never been more excited
in my life, then this moment.
- I have to confess. I haven't
been won over yet by oysters.
- Wait, seriously?
- Yeah, seriously.
- That makes me so sad, though.
Oysters are so good.
- I know, and I'm trying really hard,
but they are just snot rocks.
- Let's shuck these oysters.
- We're gonna start with the Coffin Bay.
- Twist it, and shave it inside the sides,
and then voila.
- Let's see who does it better.
- Aaa.
- That just doesn't look fabulous.
- Cheers. To Sydney.
Mmm. Oh, yeah.
- That is the saltiest
oyster I've ever had.
I'm not disgusted.
- It just, (inhales deeply), you know,
it became one with me.
- I mean when you're doing
an episode about seafood
that is as pure of a taste of the sea
as I think we're gonna get.
- You wanna go with the Sydney Rock now?
- I'm very curious to see the differences
between these. That's the funnest
part about eating oysters.
You get these tight little
packages, and each one
is gonna be a little bit different.
That is very, pretty ugly.
- Ugly delicious.
That's what Investigator Chang says.
- Holy sh*#$
- Yeah, dog.
- That is so good.
- Ohh.
- Whoa. That was like a delicate cheese.
- Imagine a world, where
humans have not ruined
the world with our smog. An
ocean beach, amazing waves,
and that fresh breeze of air.
That, is that oyster. Perfection.
- I could eat a dozen of those,
and that's the first time
I've ever thought that
about an oyster.
- You an oyster boy now?
- I think I might be an oyster boy now.
Birds are ...
- Birds know what's up.
They're oyster boys, too.
That was crazy. I've had a
lot of oysters in my life.
The American ones don't stand
a chance at this. I'm sorry.
Whoo.
That was easily my favorite
location, food, anything
that we've ever done on this show.
Australian seafood fact.
- Oh dear. Don't do that.
- Did you know that the
Australian seafood industry
is about 2.8 billion dollars.
- With a B?
- With a B. For big ones.
- Just by looking at a atlas of the world,
you know that Australia is
getting some great fish.
- So we're on the way
to the next location,
which I cannot imagine would
come close to that kind
of experience that we just had. But,
- Wow, we are,
- We can sure try.
- That is the premise of the show.
(upbeat music)
- My name's Brent Savage. I'm Chef owner
of Cirrus Restaurant. Cirrus,
for us, is all about seafood.
What we wanted to serve
at Cirrus, in our minds,
it was always to be simple.
It was to be accessible.
It was to be sustainable.
And not add too many flavors,
so that it brings out the best
in each piece. Today's dish
that we're going to have,
is live Marron.
- Forgive me, but what is a Marron?
- So Marron is Australian
freshwater crayfish.
The flavor of Marron is
actually quite strong.
So it can tolerate other flavors with it.
We're going to split the Marron in half.
We're going to clean out the
head, fill it with a little
bit of Marron butter which
we've made from the shells
of Marron. Glaze a little
bit of salt over it.
Simply cook it over the charcoal.
I don't like cooking just
about anything in water.
All water really does is
reduce the amount of flavor.
Bring it off the heat, let
the residual heat slowly cook
the remainder of the flesh through.
We're gonna serve it
with a Yuzu Kosha sauce.
Yuza Kosha is a type of ferment.
We have the native herbs,
which is, sort of a burst of saltiness.
We're finishing the dish with
a little bit of finger lime.
Finger lime is an ingredient
which is native to Australia.
So you've got layers of the sweet meat,
sour from the finger lime,
salty from the herbs.
It's quite a delicious dish.
- So we started the day
off a little casual,
but now we're getting a little Cirrus.
- That's probably the best
pun you've ever done. Okay.
- No way. So we're having
some Australian Marron.
We're having some Australian garnishes.
We're also having some
Australian wine. Do you like it?
- Ooh.
- I can't tell if you like
it or not. I like it a lot.
- It's really strong.
- This is the most excited
I've ever been for a dish.
- Plating, garnishes, meat,
beauty. It's just, everything.
(relaxing music)
- That is delightful.
- I need a moment. I'm like,
- Ooh.
- I'm gonna cry.
- This is far superior meat to lobster.
It is not quite as tender, but the flavor,
- Flavor, yeah. Oh, yeah.
- It is so good.
- You want the Marron
flavor, and double up on it.
You can really see it come through.
- The little pearls of the
finger lime, are f-*$# next level
because you don't taste it
until they burst in your mouth.
- I don't want to finish
this 'cause I just don't want
this to end.
- You've got some meat
left over here, bro.
- Wait, that's for Adam.
Yeah, stop. That's for Adam.
Look at you. You don't think
about our crew, our people.
- We can get him his own.
- Whatever.
- Right?
- That was mad good.
- Double marinated Marron.
- Surprise fact. Here's a
fact that I got interested in
while eating at Cirrus, and
I took the time to Google it
just now.
Lobsters and other shellfish,
like the crayfish we just had,
start one color, and then turn
another when they're cooked.
Because there are a bunch
of different pigments
in the shell of a lobster.
But there's one that's called,
Astaxanthin.
Astaxanthin, that is the only
one that's stable in heat.
- Do you think if you would've boiled it,
what color do you think would come out?
- It would just be a burst of light
that would sear your retinas.
- Name as many cities as
you can in Australia. Go.
- Perth. Garmin. Sydney. Brisbane.
Melbourne. Alice Springs.
I also know where we're going
because this trip was planned
for in advance.
- It is Melbourne. By
the power of movie magic,
you will not have to sit with
us for the next five hours.
- Unfortunately, I will.
- It's cold. Melbourne.
Melbourne.
- Melbourne.
- Melbourne. We're in Melbourne.
- So, we're on our way right
now to the last seafood spot.
What is happening?
- I'm Bernard. I'm the Chef de
Cuisine in Silks, Melbourne.
Silks is more of a traditional
Cantonese cooking restaurant.
Today we gonna introduce the
braised green lip Abalone.
Green lip Abalone is one
of the most luxurious item
you can eat because how it's
caught. It's hand-dived.
They're actually harvested
about forty minutes,
down the sea bay. They're found on reefs.
- Wow. You said it's a luxury item.
The most luxurious seafood you can get.
- Yep.
- How much is it to order here?
- It can be a bit pricey.
$178 per 100 grams.
- Do we request that, I
want one kilogram, or I want
100 grams, or,
- That's correct. Usually a
lot of people come in and,
they have a sharing. If you
gonna have that for entree,
it's a lot to have.
- And how would you describe
the flavor of Abalone.
- I would say very seafoody.
It's flavorsome.
It's a whole mouthful. We
receive the live Abalone
from our online suppliers. We chop them,
and then we clean off the guts.
We clean off the skirtings.
After the Abalone's been
blanched, we fill in the bag
with the stock, with oyster
sauce and Chinese wine.
I know the traditional
way people doing it.
They put the Abalone straight in the pot.
But what we realize is
that it loses its shape.
So what we do is we actually
soux it, slow cook it,
so it maintains its shape, in the flavor,
in its own juice, so, double the flavor.
We serve it, actually,
with a Japanese mushroom,
served with two bokchoy.
- Very simple.
- Very simple. Very classic,
but it's very flavorful.
- What is this?
- This is the Mongolian tent
at Silk's. It's usually not
for two people, but I had to do it.
- I feel like I'm at a
Chinese New Year dinner.
Now we've flown all the
way to Melbourne to try
the green lip Abalone, and this
is how gold should be served
in a subtle, classic way.
- I like how you now have
preferences on how gold
should be served on your food.
It is awesome that this is
dived for by hand forty meters down.
You basically have to be the
ocean version of an astronaut
to do that.
- So, a scuba diver?
- Yeah.
- This smells so good. It smells rich.
- Cheers.
- Wow. Wow.
- Wow. That's pretty good.
- That's really good.
- It has a very satisfying
texture. It's both firm,
but supple.
- Supple. That's like if you
took scallop and an oyster,
and you combined the flavors together.
- It is crazy that you
have this just solid blob
of deliciousness.
- Yes.
- How often else does
that happen in nature?
- Shout out to nature.
- I am so contented. We're
in a tent. Video over.
- Just love seafood. It's so good.
We had three seafood dishes at two cities.
Which seafood was the
most worth it, to you,
at its given price?
- Here's the deal. I had the
best oyster I've ever had
at Doyle's Oyster Bar
at the city fish market.
I didn't think oysters could be that good.
But Cirrus, the grilled
Marron, Worth It Winner.
That was really one of
the best sea creature
eating experiences I've ever had.
My arm is tired. Can you hold this?
- My turn. So, the Abalone
was quite a steep price,
although it was definitely
worth the experience.
Sydney fish market. I
thought for sure that was
gonna be my Worth It Winner going in.
But all that being said, Cirrus is also
my Worth It Winner today.
I mean, come on, that place
was ridiculous.
- Adam, what's your Worth It Winner?
- Nice.
- What's it called? Worth It Three Way?
- Worth-agatrois.
- No, no, no. Three Way Worth
It Winner. That does it.
- Yeah.
- For Part One. We're here in Australia.
We got more coming. We're gonna do wine.
We're gonna do steak.
- ♫ She sells seashells by the
seashore. She sells seashells
by the seashore.
(beatboxing rap)
- Oh, yes.